Now that we've covered those concepts, let's actually jump into the engine.
Let's figure out how to use these concepts in a practical way.
And the best way to demonstrate this is by creating a light switch interaction between
a player and multiple blueprints.
So what we'll do is we will open a new project.
We'll use the third person template here, which is in the game setting.
Project name doesn't matter so much, but for this instance, we've called it the course
And then you just want to create a project location of where these files will be stored.
Once we have the editor open, I'm going to show you quickly what we're making today,
just so you have context.
So I'm just going to jump in to play an editor by hitting Alt P, alternatively you
can just press play.
We spawn as a player, we run over to this blue box, we press the input E and it turns
a light off and then we can toggle that indefinitely by hitting E on the keyboard
to make sure the light turns on and off.
So let's figure out how we do this using the concepts that we've just learned.
The first thing you want to do when you have a project open is to add a specific
input mode or input binding, shall we say, that allows you to press E on the keyboard,
for example, to create some kind of input.
So to do that, we'll go to edit, we'll go to project settings.
When project settings loads, we'll scroll down to input in the engine section.
So when we go to input here, some of these boxes may be condensed here, but we're looking
for these two action and axis mapping options.
What we'll do is we'll add a new action mapping, so add action mapping, we'll type
use action or whatever kind of input you would like.
And then on the keyboard, we're going to input E.
So I'm just going to press E and try and find E on the action mappings.
So E can be there.
And if you want to add gamepad functionality, you can maybe add game face button left
if you want it to work with controller.
And that's how you'll add input into your game.
So on the axis mapping, the move forward and backwards, you'll already have all these
as defaults with the project, but just in case, I'll expand these out if you wanted
to see what was going on here.
All default functionality, but if your project isn't set up in a certain way, again, if
you've used a third person template, everything should be working there.
But they're the input mappings that we have, and that will allow us to create an input
inside of our blueprint.
So we can shut the project settings now.
They automatically save as you edit them.
And then, so we've already got all of our blueprints here, but what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a second folder just so we can follow along one to one.
So I'm just going to in the third person, I'm going to add a new folder and I'll call
this tutorial.
And so the first thing we want to do is create a blueprint interface.
These are the things that we've been talking about.
A good naming convention for blueprint interface is BPI.
So I'm going to right click and then it'll be under blueprints and then you've got
a blueprint interface.
So I'm going to add a blueprint interface.
I'm going to call that BP lowercase I for blueprint interface.
And then you can name this whatever you would want.
I'm going to call this a usable actor.
So usable actor, and we've got a blueprint interface.
So then we can load this blueprint interface.
I like to pin my tabs alongside the map.
So it's easy to go back and forth.
You can do that however you want.
I'm just going to compile and save just to make sure everything is saving correctly.
And then in the class settings, we want to make sure that the interfaces section is
all set up okay.
And to do that, we'll create an empty blueprint for now.
So we'll then go back into our content browser.
We'll right click, go to blueprints and this time we'll create a blueprint class.
So you can just create it from an actor class, which is the most basic version of
a blueprint and we'll call this BP underscore and again, usable actor.
So this will be inheriting the interface.
So I'll just add that and we're going to double click or you can press enter if it's
selected on the keyboard to open it up.
Again we have our class settings here and the difference between this blueprint
and this blueprint interface, you can see it just holds options here.
Whereas the actor actually has this interface section in the class settings.
So we can add this now.
So we can add an interface and because of our naming convention, our BPI underscore naming
convention, we'll see that we can now inherit an interface from here, which is
because we've used our naming convention, it makes it really easy to find.
Once you've added it, you need to make sure you compile and save and then that allows
you to communicate with this blueprint from this blueprint interface.
So let's create a second interface now from the tutorial deck, we mentioned that we needed
two interfaces.
So again, we're going to right click, blueprints, blueprint interface, and again, I'll call
this BPI and I'll call this activatable interface.
So we'll just call it activatable interface.
We'll add that and now we want to create something that is activatable by this interface.
So again, we're going to create an empty blueprint class.
So there's a little bit of setup here, but once you've got these actors set up,
that's where the power comes in with our parent and child classes as we were talking
about before.
So hopefully they're all straightforward steps, but we'll just go ahead and create another
blueprint class.
So we'll right click blueprints, blueprint class, we're going to select actor again,
I'm going to call this BP underscore, and then we'll call it activatable actor.
And again, we want to make sure it has the correct interface.
So we want to double click it.
We'll go to class settings, we'll go to add, go to BPI again, and now we've got
the activatable interface.
And since we've got, we should really keep these naming conventions similar as well,
just to make sure, you know, just the flow of communication is correct.
So I'm going to select activatable interface here, but I think what I'm going to do,
I'm going to rename that BPI usable actor.
I'm just going to select it.
You can either right click and go to rename, you can press F2 to rename, or you can
just select it once and then select it twice and then it'll go to renaming.
So I'm going to call this interface.
Let's just file, save all, and I'm just going to open up my usable actor just to
make sure the interface is the correct one.
I'm not necessarily happy that that's still there.
I want to make sure there's no communication issues down the line.
So I'm just going to clear that out.
So yes, and there we go.
We've got the usable interface.
Okay, so let's go to BPI underscore, and there we go.
I think that would be a cleaner way of working.
We just want to compile and save that.
Activatable actor has the activatable interface, the usable actor has the usable interface.
That'll just make things cleaner.
The communication flow is just going to be much better.
Just going to make sure I've saved everything and then we'll move on to the next step.
If we look at how we want to interact with our light switch now, we have this
interaction controller at the top and an interaction controller can then possess one of these
avatars as we were talking about before, whether that's a humanoid character, we've
got a car, a spaceship, a ball, we can create some kind of interaction controller
that communicates with these.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we'll create an interaction controller.
So we'll right click, we'll go to a new blueprint class.
We'll create a now player controller because now we want something that we're controlling
a palm with.
So we'll select player controller there and we'll call this interaction controller.
Then we'll hit enter to open it up.
We'll go to the blueprint graph here, sorry.
You want to make sure that parent class is player controller at the top.
So if it's not, just make sure you have that there.
I'm just going to select these and delete them.
Just hit and delete on the keyboard just to make sure we have everything that we need.
I'll make that details panel a bit smaller.
So the first input we want to add here is the thing that we added at the start.
So that'll be the use action.
Now use action, if you remember, so I'll select that, but use action, you don't have
to go here, but I'm going to go to edit project settings, go back to input.
So you'll see that we got, we have use action here.
So whatever we call this here, that's what we're looking for in this controller.
So wherever our controller is, let's open it up again.
I must have closed it.
That's what this use action is here.
So the concept of interacting with objects in the world inside of unreal engine is to
create a line trace.
Now go over the theory of line trace in a second.
Let's go ahead and start creating a line trace just so you see what is happening blueprint-wise.
So we want to create a line trace by channel.
So that will be the top one here and a line trace by channel essentially needs
a start and an end point.
So the start point is going to be the controlled pawn who we are currently controlling.
So we'll get the controlled pawn and you'll, you'll generally set up a line trace once
and then not need to do it again for your projects.
You may get into the habit of making these.
There are documentations online about creating a basic line trace for a player on the unreal
engine documentation page.
If you ever just want to reference that, this can just be made into a copy and paste
option as well.
So you can use it in various projects.
So from the controlled pawn, we want to get the actor location.
So get actor location, and we also want to get the forward vector.
So we'll get the forward vector and that's basically the direction that we're currently
looking in.
What we'll do then is we'll add these two properties together.
So we want to add one vector to another.
So I'm just going to use my plus icon here and we'll add one to the other.
Now if I just add both of these two directly, it's going to give me a location
directly in front of the player's current cursor view.
What I want to do is I actually want to multiply this vector.
So I'm just going to go to multiply.
You can either type in multiply or use the star for multiply.
And actually I want to multiply by a float.
So I want to, what is the multiply?
Let's try float.
So yeah, I want to right click on the pin, convert pin into a float.
So that creates a float there.
And now what I want to do is I want to set some kind of units.
Now I'm just going to put 2000 by default.
2000 is just a good interact distance.
We could even promote this to a variable and change the interact distance based on
certain functionality, but we'll leave it simple for now.
We'll just project 2000 units into the world.
Then I'll add these two vectors together.
So I'll add them.
And so the start location is going to be the player.
So I can just go directly into the star.
And the end location is this location that we've projected out into this world based
on the float.
Now an actor that we want to ignore here.
So these properties are all the same.
We do have ignore self here, but just to make sure that we are definitely ignoring
all components of our self.
What we'll do is we'll get the controlled pawn, which is here.
We'll make an array and hit enter.
And then we can also just drag that into that.
I'll double click here on the line just to make a reroute node, but essentially that's
going to be our line trace if I bring it in to a view here.
So we've got our input action, we've got a line trace, and then we've got our functions
that make up the line trace.
And I'll just highlight all this and call this basic line trace.
You can add some flavor to your comment boxes if you want.
I'll drop the alpha.
Maybe you make the text bigger.
This is like a core piece of scripting inside of your controller.
So maybe you want to add some kind of flavor to that.
So just highlight where it is in your level, but that's the basic line trace.
So now what do we want to do after we've traced into the world?
Now we essentially want to know what have we hit.
Before I explain that cliffhanger, I'll compile and save as well, just to make sure we don't
lose any code.
So on our out hit result, you want to use something called a break hit result.
And this essentially just gives you lots of options.
If you click the little dropdown arrow, it gives you all the things that you could
possibly have hit with the trace.
Now all we really care about is the hit actor.
We care about have we hit an actor that we can interact with?
If yes, what do we want to do?
Well, we can use this concept called does implement interface that we used before.
So yes, we want to use that.
And then we also want to type in BPI and we want to know what interface to use here.
Now it's going to be the usable interface in this instance, the one that we used.
I'll branch here.
So I'll drag off the red pin and type branch and add that here, dragging out there.
And then from the hit actor, we want to call the interface that we hit.
So again, I'm going to compile and save just to make sure we have all the correct
logic up to date.
I'm going to drag out of hit actor and type use object, which is going to be a message.
So it's going to be a message for anyone that wants to listen and it's going to be
able to listen because we know it can listen because it's got the interface assigned to
it.
If, if this had returned false, well, we'd know that whatever actor we hit in the world
didn't have this interface, therefore we can't use the object.
So it's a good kind of prevention system because technically we could have just, you
don't have to do this, but we could have just gone directly into that.
I'm going to hold alt to break that pin.
We could have just said, use object, whatever you're trying to do, just use objects on
everything you hit.
That wouldn't have been as good because we don't know that half of these objects have
these interfaces.
So you could be trying to click on stuff that doesn't implement a certain interface
and crashes and bugs and just many issues could happen.
So with this security check here, does implement interface, it allows us to ensure that we're
speaking to the right object.
So I'm just going to hit undo a few times, make sure all that's there.
And that's essentially our, our basic trace that we want in, in our player controller.
So again, I'm going to compile, save, and then I'm just going to close that.
So we don't have too many windows open and I go back to the map and you just want
to make sure you save and we'll go to the next step.
The next thing we want to do is just to make sure our game mode is set correctly.
So in the blueprints, again, if you had been doing your new scripting inside of this
original blueprints folder, which comes with the project, you'll see the character here,
the third person game mode.
And so if we actually open up this game mode, you'll see that the player controller
class is set to interaction controller.
So I have two here just because I made a new one.
So you, you, you will only have one in this instance.
So just make sure interaction controller is selected there.
That means that the game mode, so it runs what kind of hood you should have,
what kind of porn you are currently possessing, which in our instance is a third person character.
This essentially gives you all your game set up properties.
So you just want to make sure that that controller class is selected there before you continue.
And then you can close it, go back to our map, save all, and then we can continue.
So next, I'm going to go back into my tutorial folder here.
If you're in your blueprints folder, definitely stay there.
And so now we want to create a light switch to interact with inside of our level.
And we want to do this from the activatable actor.
Now when we're talking about the concepts of parent and child classes before,
we're going to create a child class based on this parent class.
So this is our parent class.
So I'm going to right click on our parent class and go to at the top of the page here,
create child blueprint class.
You want to create a child class.
I'm going to call this BP underscore light.
You could have some kind of naming convention that says child at the end.
I'm going to call it that just so you can see exactly what's going on.
You don't need to add child.
If you have your own naming convention of how to do parent classes and child classes,
that's also okay.
I'm just going to make sure our file save.
You'll see that saving often is always a good way to prevent any issues here.
So we want to open up this light child.
We want to add a component.
So again, we were talking about components before in the tutorial.
So we want to add component and this instance will add a point light.
I'm just going to leave it named as point light.
I might change the color of it.
Let's just stay in our pink theme.
The radius will be fine.
You can change any properties here if you want.
Maybe I'll draw up the intensity just so you can really see it.
You can make whatever kind of light you want.
You could add a little fixture or setting or something like that.
I'm just going to save that.
And then the main thing we want to actually do in this blueprint is to go to the event
graph here and you'll see interestingly, it's not part of this tutorial, but you'll
see that we've got a parent begin play and our begin play.
So everything always fires off the parent before we are firing into the child class.
So that's really useful to know, but we're going to go to event activate object.
So we just want to make sure our interface is set.
So we've got an inherited interface here, which is a activatable interface.
So let's make sure we have our interface.
So activate, activate object there.
We actually want the activate object.
We want to make sure it's not the message.
So before we can add any code here, we want to go to our third person map again.
We want to go to the activatable interface and then we just need a function here.
So we need to create a new function and we'll just call this activate object.
So I'll give it a capital letter on the O and that'll make sure that it puts a space
between activate and object.
So whenever you capitalize functions like that, so there's no space in the actual function,
but you can see a space there, which is for visual purposes, which is quite a nice
little touch inside of unreal.
It means that you can name things correctly in the function, but obviously it makes things
a bit more visual on the front end here.
So I'm just going to compile and save that.
And then we want to go to our light.
We want to compile and save our light, and then hopefully we have an event activate
objects here.
So you'll find activate objects there.
If you don't have that, you just want to make sure you compile and save that'll
refresh the code.
And now we just want to do something.
How do we activate this light?
Well, maybe we want to add the point light and we want to toggle the visibility, which
is just some basic default unreal engine functionality.
Again, I just dragged and dropped the point light in there.
That's how I get the point light.
I drag off the blue pin, type in toggle visibility, and you can just hook that in there.
Something basic, we'll compile and save, and that allows us to toggle the visibility
of the point light when we receive this message from the blueprint interface.
So this message, again, it's just a wrapper.
It's just essentially just saying, here's a message I want you to do something.
And the actual functionality is inside this light blueprint.
Now we need some kind of switch in our level.
We've got our lights, so I'm just going to find a part of the map over here.
I'm going to add my lights to it.
So I'll add my pink light so you can see the difference between the white light over
there and the pink light.
Now I will create some kind of light switch blueprint.
So again, we want to create a child based on the usable actor this time.
So we created an activatable actor, now we want to go to usable actor.
So on the usable actor, create a child blueprint.
We'll call this BP underscore switch.
And again, I'll name it child so you can see exactly what's going on there.
And then I will open up this switch child.
So again, we just want to make sure we have some kind of function inside of our first
usable interface.
So BPI underscore usable interface, it created a new function here.
We'll just rename this to use objects, for example.
Now you can see use objects is there.
We'll make sure we compile, save, and I'm going to start closing these windows.
I'll close that one and I'll close that one just so we can see exactly what's going
on.
I'll probably also close these.
I'm just middle mousing to close them because we only really care about the two child blueprints
at the moment.
So when I go back into this switch, I'm going to compile and save to make sure that I have
the required code, it's updated it.
And then we just need some kind of static mesh in here.
So I will add a cube, for example, I'm not sure how big that scale of cube is, so I'm
going to scale it.
I'm going to go into the map, I'm going to drag out the switch.
And so you can see that this cube is a little bit big.
So maybe I'll go back into the blueprint and scale it maybe by a 0.5, something like
that.
Well, that's 0.6.
Actually, let's leave it at that.
That's kind of a nice switch shape.
So that'll be our switch in the map.
Whatever you want it to look like, aesthetic doesn't matter so much in this instance,
but that's going to be my light switch.
So let's go to the switch.
Let's go again back to the event graph.
And then we want to right click and type use object.
Now you want to make sure that we select the event here.
Well, I just selected the wrong one, sorry.
So event use object at the top, that's the one that you want.
And we want to, first of all, get the light variable.
So we want to create a light.
So to do that, we'll create a new variable and we'll call this light actor or something
similar to that.
So we're actually looking for this, this light that we've placed in our map.
So we want to make sure we change the variable type here from Boolean to whatever
we named our light child at the top.
So we called it BP underscore light underscore child, and you'll see that here and we'll
create an object reference.
So now we'll have a variable, which is light child.
So I'm going to drag that out.
I'm going to hold down control and left mouse drag to get.
If you don't hold down control, you get a get on a set.
So you can just click get in that instance.
Alternatively, you can hold down alt for a set.
We just don't need set.
So control and alt are shortcuts there.
Just for good practice, as your blueprints get bigger as well, I'm going to change
the category here to a light properties and it gives us its own little category.
I'm also going to expose it with that little, uh, I, I, uh, variable that I'm going to
compile and save.
Now we want to do that is valid.
Like we said before, we want to do that is valid.
Alternatively, if you would like, you can drag this out and you can right click on
the blue pin and convert to a valid get, and we could use that option.
Whichever option, both are exactly the same.
I'll just delete this one cause this one's already in place.
So we want to get is valid.
And then from the light actor, we want to go to activate object.
We want to select that there.
Now there were multiple activate objects, um, let's just see here.
You can have the, it says available interface, which is a message.
So that one is also because it was in the available interfaces.
That one's more solid connection is the object reference there.
Whereas that's the activatable interface reference.
Both should work, but I'm going to go with the most secure option right now.
So I'll just drag that in there and I'll compile and save.
And so, yeah, we just want to make sure these actors are in the level and then we
just want to make sure this light is referenced.
So let's go back into our map.
If we click on our switch now, you'll see this light actor variable here, which was
in our light properties.
So you notice that we gave it a category heading, which is what that is.
So I've got back into my switch.
So light properties is what I called this category here.
I also exposed the variable.
So that's why we can see it here.
And then we just want to make sure that we select the BP underscore light child in there.
If there's multiple actors, you can, I drop it and select it from there, but let's just
give it a test.
Let's see if our functionality is working and if not, hopefully we'll figure out how
to debug it.
So let's, let's go over to the switch.
I'll press E and it's not working in this instance.
So let's just see what's going on.
So I'm going to open my third person game mode.
I'm going to make sure my interaction controller is set correctly.
I'm going to find that that interaction controller is not right.
So let me just change that interaction controller and that's in my tutorial folder now.
So that's good.
Once I have the interaction controller open so I can shut my game mode, I'm going to
go into my basic trace and I just want to see what's going on in my trace.
So the real estate on the window is going to be a little weird here, but I just want
to make sure that this trace is actually hitting something and going through.
So let's just make sure our input is working first of all.
So you'll see if I use this dropdown here, no debug options selected, interaction controller.
So when I'm pressing E you see that firing out there, you see that line.
So you'll see that the code is actually firing through to the use object.
So that's good.
So use object is firing.
So we know that the interaction is actually working.
So now let's see if it's breaking at the switch.
So I'll shut the interaction controller now.
And now we just want to make sure the switch is working.
So I just want to make sure activate object is the actual BPI version of the activatable
object.
And therefore when I delete that, connect it up, control that, alt P to play.
Let's try and just make sure we go in there, press E and therefore the tutorial is working.
So that is how to set up a basic switch inside of unreal engine using blueprint interfaces.
So it's definitely worth having to play around inside of unreal engine, getting used
to your blueprint interfaces and creating basic switches and things like this.
Sometimes it can be trial and error, but it's good to just debug through your work,
figure out what's not working and you'll learn a lot more that way.
So also consider making the target an array and a for each loop.
So that might be interesting to control multiple lights.
You could even open a door where they use, you can control lights and doors and other
blueprints by activating the switch.
So just have a play around in the projects and think about the different functionality
you have from these tutorials.